في الحقيقه المناطق الحدوديه القريبه من
الحدود السوريه التركيه في شمال غرب سوريا
كانت هي المناطق التي اخذت الحظ الاوفر من
عمليات الانهيار او سقوط المباني تحديدا
في منطقه جنديرس في ريف عفرين كانت مدينه
منكوبه بالكامل في منطقه حارم منطقه سلقين
منطقه بسنيه هي المناطق القريبه من منطقه
حارم ايضا هي منطقه حدوديه كمان ايضا
عناله نصيب كبير من الانهيارات والضحايا
في منطقه سرمدا الدانه ترمانين التي هي
قريبه من المعبر باب الهواء كان لها ايضا
حظا وافر من هذه الهيارات وكان هناك
العديد من الاشخاص تحت الانقاض واستطعنا
انتشار للعديد من الاشخاص من تحت الانقاذ
ولكن لا زال هناك عالقين وبدانا نفقد
الوقت باكثر من 30 او 31 ساعه عمل حتى
الان يعني بدا الوقت يمر هذا الوقت ليس من
صالح هؤلاء العالقين بدانا نفقد حياه بعض
العال تحت الانقاذ بسبب صعوبه الاعداد
العالقين كبيره هل تتواصلون معهم
نعم نعم للاسف هناك اعداد كبيره لازال نحن
نتكلم عن اكثر من 700 موقع عمل 700 انهيار
منتشر في شمال غرب سوريا فنحن نتحدث عن
اعداد كبيره هي موجوده تحت الانقاذ حاليا
نستطيع ان نسمع بعض الاصوات نستطيع نحاول
ان نصل الى هذه الاصوات استطعنا انتشار
اكثر من 22 مصاب من تحت لانقاذ في خلال
العمل 30 ساعه الماضيه ايضا استطعنا ان
ننتشر ما يقارب 800 يعني قتيل او جثه
الماضيه لا زلنا نسمع اصوات حتى الان ولكن
نحن نخشى اذا تاخر الوصول الى هذه الاصوات
ان نفقدها وان نصل الى جثث ولا نصل الى
يعني الى اي مدى في تقديراتكم هم قادرون
على الصمود ضمن هذه الظروف الصعبه
الحقيقه الظروف صعبه وكما قلت نحن في سباق
حقيقي مع الزمن الظروف صعبه الظروف
انهيارات والناس تحت الانقاض بالاضافه الى
ظرف الشتاء يعني المطر لم يفارق اجواء
شمال غرب سوريا منذ اللحظات الاولى من
وقوع هذا الزلزال وحتى الان فهناك امطار
وهناك ثلوج في بعض المناطق اللي هي التي
تزيد تزيد المعاناه هل هي التي تؤدي الى
بروده يعني اجساد الاشخاص الموجودين تحت
الانقاض وهذا يساهم بتقليل فرصهم للصمود
اكثر وهذا يزيد معاناتها معاناه اكبر
فلذلك كما تقول نحن في سباق حقيقي مع
الزمن نحن ناشدنا منذ اللحظات الاولى كافه
الدول العالم ان ان تصل المساعدات لفرق
القوات البيضاء الفرق الدفاع الذي شمال
غرب سوريا حتى نستطيع ان ننقذ الاحياء من
تحت هذه الانقاذ حتى هذه اللحظه للاسف لم
تصل اي مساعدات حقيقيه الى شمال غرب سوريا
يعني نستطيع ان نقول انها ساهمت بمساعده
الفرق العامله على الارض